le rapport de jacques toubon défenseur
des droits donc se concluait sur ceux ci
que la somme de ses discrimination
systémique qui a fait effectivement
notamment et les populations racisées et
les immigrés et les héritiers de
l'immigration coloniale et postcoloniale
contribuent très fortement à remettre en
cause ce qu'il appelait au fond le pacte
républicain ce que pour beaucoup
d'autres appellent ainsi et au fond ce
qui était constaté c'est que les
principes républicains n'étaient pas
effectifs dans nombre de quartiers
je reprendrai aussi cette expression et
cette formule que j'aime beaucoup de
robert badinter qui disait la france et
le pays de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme
la france n'est pas le pays des droits
de l'homme et on pourrait dire aussi que
la france est certes le pays des
principes républicains mais que la
france n'est pas encore hélas ce pays où
ces principes sont effectifs la preuve
la situation où les situations qui sont
faites à l'ensemble des populations et
racisées et à l'ensemble des populations
qui vivent dans les quartiers populaires
et qui à l'évidence sont victimes donc
de discrimination systémique qui
remettent en cause ses principes la
liberté l'égalité et bien sûr la
fraternité parce que ils sont
stigmatisés et dans le discours eu des
malaises macro relativement au
séparatisme et c'est un saut qualitatif
et langagier politique qui me paraît
très important
ils sont désignés comme faisant peser
une menace existentielle sur l'unité
nationale et l'unité républicaine et de
l'or qu'on les désigne un si grand est
le risque effectivement de légitimer
d'une part des discours d'une extrême
violence politique et symbolique et
au-delà de ces discours de justifier et
deux légitimes et hélas aussi des
pratiques discriminatoires plus grave
encore à la rencontre
[Musique]